whether it's to map the stars spy on
other planets or study the Sun humors
have been looking to the skies for
millennia but some objects are safer to
observe than others for example
astronomer Mark Thompson put a pig's eye
behind a regular telescope and aimed it
at the Sun and it burned a hole straight
through the lens in about 20 seconds now
looking at the Sun through a telescope
is an especially terrible idea but just
how bad is it to glance up with the
naked eye on a clear day if the Sun
shines up to five thousand times
brighter than average light bulb when
something that bright strikes your eye a
few things can happen if it's only for a
moment the worse you'll experience is a
blurry splotch on your vision called an
after image normally light reaches the
retina at the back of your eye where it
triggers photoreceptors that relay the
information to your brain this is how
you're able to see anything but bombard
them with too much light at once and you
can actually damage the cells and
proteins that help them process light
since your retina has no pain receptors
the damage won't hurt but it will leave
the blurry splotch on your vision
usually it clears up in a few minutes
that is unless you keep staring now
you're doing more damage than just
overloading your retina for starters
you're giving your eyes an abnormally
high dose of UV radiation the same stuff
that causes sunburns like your skin the
cornea at the front of your eye can also
burn and that will hurt the cornea
protects the rest of your eye and is
therefore covered in pain receptors that
alert you whenever a pesky eyelash is on
the loose but UV radiation isn't the
only issue too much visible light can
penetrate your eye and damage the
retinal tissue which causes a condition
called solar retinitis
this means parts of your retina can no
longer process light normally so you can
end up with entire chunks of your vision
blurred out depending on the extent of
the damage recovery can take weeks
months and in severe cases over a year
but in rare cases the damage is so
extreme it never heals leading to a rare
condition called solar retinopathy this
usually only shows up in reckless
Eclipse gazers turns out during a solar
eclipse most of the sun's light is
blocked which can actually trick your
brain into thinking it's safe to stare
normally our bodies have a built-in
defense mechanism against staring at the
Sun specifically when we squint we look
up which minimizes the amount of light
coming in and protect our cornea and
retina but during a solar eclipse the
Sun doesn't appear bright enough to
trigger our defense mechanisms so we can
end up staring for longer than is safe
suffice to say there's nothing good
about staring at the Sun so do your eyes
a favor and avoid looking at it after
all
there are around 6,000 stars in the
night sky which you can safely observe
for as long as you wish